[Music]
Resident Evil 6 takes place 14 years
actually original residential title it
follows four different characters Chris
Redfield Leon Kennedy Ada Wong a
newcomer to the series Jake Muller in
this episode we're going to concentrate
on Chris Redfield and his journey
through the game so let's do this
another round Chris Redfield story
begins at a bar where he drinking
himself into oblivion just before he
beats a local to death 10 steps piers
Nibin who short crisp images from his
past never thought I'd find Chris
Redfield wasting awareness [ __ ] all like
this it turns out that mr. Redfield is
suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder and has forgotten the man he
once was
luckily piers had lots of bottles of
burning cities and dead teammates to
jolt Chrissy's memory and instantly
cured amnesia can hide in your mouth no
matter where you go or what you do
Christie exchange of a BSA a team and
heads off to China to fight a fresh
batch of C virus infused enemies known
as the schwa though after showing his
prowess with a gun he is shattered by
the reoccurring memories of his old
teammates who have died under his
leadership we see he's acted out in a
flashback scene where Chris and chums
are fighting a group of rebels who have
been infected with the C virus we are
now introduced to Sheri Birkin yes the
girl from re - who is now a government
agent Sheri is escorting mercenary Jake
Muller back to the US for tests on
potential antibodies he possesses Sheri
and GX jump on the helicopter but Chris
can't shake the feeling he knows Jake
from somewhere okay hey
we met Chrissy's team continued
searching the surrounding area and find
you C virus sample in walk Aida one in
her blue attire to add another
revelation umbrella umbrella may be dead
but neo umbrella have taken on the
mantle with the ambition of destroying
the entire world sounds like a lovely
place to work thanks Pierce good here's
something to remember me by
suddenly Ada Wong inspects the squad
with the C virus and peers and Chris are
forced to watch their friends die and
become the enemy
not like they
Oh
Christie eggs are heavy not to the head
but he is dragged into safety and the
flashback and it is now clear that Chris
has only come back to kill either one
and take down neo umbrella next up Chris
and the gang fights a helicopter and
then fight an invisible snake which they
kill with electricity in through this
area to infect another one of Chris's
men chris is now fully unhinged and
revenge is causing him to make mistakes
which are costing the lives of others
Chris and Peter's finally tracked down
Ada and I just about to end her life
when this happened Leon Kennedy said
added life and the two biggest names in
resident evil history based off their
thanks for the intervention ADA throw
the flashbang grenade at our heroes and
escaped promptly Chris Antley is once
again catch up with Ada who is now
wearing red oh no no she's in blue
against anyway Chris delivers a chilling
monologue but is interrupted by a
helicopter shooting ADA through the
chest and she literally goes black
[Music]
dammit we are now sold the error or the
diversion and the real attack is about
to happen and spread the virus worldwide
staffing at this very city a single
rocket escapes our heroes and heads
towards the local popular
it's like Raccoon City all over again
everyone is infected and he's almost
certain that neo umbrella have succeeded
but wait the story is not over yet
Klingon instructs Chris and fears to go
to an underwater oilfield to rescue
sherry and Jade but another regulation
is uncovered agent Cheri Burcham and
sheikh Muir stop electric shock Wesker
yeah Jake Muller is Albert Wesker stone
fire who the heck would have guessed
that well he is also inherited his
antibodies and he's immune to the C
virus good Chris free sherry and Jake
and let's Jake know about his dad I'm
the one that killed him Jake finally
shoot straight but don't worry his aim
is terrible it's just a grid let's keep
going the building starts to crumble and
our heroes must escape but it won't be
easy because of this translucent booger
that won't quit pier six a pretty heavy
hit and loses his arm but he's such a
butter so he can inject himself with the
C virus to regenerate a new one a little
different from his first limb the pair
defeat the final boss and in the
ultimate act of brotherly love piers
pushes Chris into the escape pod and I
try a little bit inside
Judy open the door
once again Chris's entire team is dead
but his devotion to pious memory is now
the driving force behind him oh we did
it
that was Resident Evil 6 Chris Redfield
ition in five minutes I don't know about
you I need to lay down after that one
coming soon we'll have versions for LJ
and Liam so please check back I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade I'll see you
next time